Welcome everybody.
We have for you tonight
Probability, risk, and chance. But before the fun starts lmao.
Something serious, a serious scientific experiment that you are all going to be apart of.
An experiment on ESP. Extrasensory perception. Aaliyah Allen
You all have cards, take out those index cards and the pencils you were given.
And I have something, it's a quarter. You just have to take my word for it. It's a regular quarter. Heads on one side, Tales on the other.
I'm going to use this quarter to generate a random message. And I'm gonna try my best to transmit it to all of you.
And your best to receive it.
Okay, the message is going to be five coin flips. Five heads or tales. Now you just write down "H" for heads or "T" for tales.